tax loss harvesting often said to be a
silver lining in a down Market
here's how it works when your
Investments go south you can sell them
from your brokerage account at a loss
and then use that loss to reduce your
tax bill in the US once your losses
exceed capital gains you can subtract up
to three thousand dollars per year from
ordinary income and if your losses
exceed three thousand that can be
carried forward to offset games in
future years that's some damage control
for portfolios in a bruising year in
which both stocks and bonds have
declined taxos harvesting could even
make the crypto crash a little less
painful crypto investors have
collectively lost trillions of dollars
since digital coins heat but they may
have a special tax advantage stock
owners have to follow What's called the
wash sale rule if they sell a stock for
a loss they have to wait 30 days before
buying the same security again or else
it won't be eligible for a deduction so
far the IRS has not said this wash cell
wall applied to digital assets still
some tax experts warn crypto investors
could get burnt by the irs's economic
substance doctrine that will basically
says that you can't do something just
for a tax benefit and if you plan on
selling crypto at a loss make sure you
know how long you've been holding your
coins anything under the one year mark
is considered a short-term capital loss
short-term losses will be used to offset
short-term gains first and then
long-term gains whilst this strategy
won't completely ease the sting of
crypto losses it may provide some relief
happy harvesting
[Music]